[Music]
do you like being tickled
first you laugh a lot it's
uncontrollable but funny
then you laugh so hard that your abs
hurt
okay stop
but what if the tickling doesn't stop
for 24 hours
could you be
tickled to death
this is your body on being tickled for
24 hours straight
there are two types of tickling the most
common is gargolysis
that's when someone touches parts of
your body repeatedly causing you to
laugh
the other type of tickling is nysmisis
that's where a light touch on your skin
causes a tickling sensation but not
laughter
the most sensitive areas are your
stomach
sides armpits
feet and neck
and the reason you can't tickle yourself
it's that there's no element of surprise
your brain knows that the sensation is
coming
but research has shown that those with
schizophrenia can tickle themselves
because their brain can't differentiate
between self-generated and externally
generated touches
so
how much tickling could the human body
handle don't do that it tickles okay
you tried to avoid it but you're now
being tickled
even the thought of it makes you giggle
you know that feeling
sometimes you're laughing but it doesn't
mean that you're enjoying it
scientists from the university of
california found that tickling doesn't
create the same laughter someone gets
from a funny joke
it's just an outward illusion
being tickled stimulates your
hypothalamus the part of your brain that
controls your emotional reactions
it's also where the physiological
reaction to an attack or threat is
activated
so when you laugh from being tickled you
have an automatic emotional response
but the body movements you make mimic
those of individuals in severe pain
a prolonged tickle would be extremely
unpleasant so
you might want to stop at this point
after one hour of non-stop giggles your
core would be extremely sore
it would be the best workout of your
life and the nastiest one
they say laughter is the best medicine
but in this case i beg to differ
okay you've been tickled for 10 hours
now it's pure torture
as a matter of fact tickling has been
used in sinister ways in the past
during the han dynasty in the 3rd
century bce
the chinese used it as torture because
the victim would suffer but it didn't
leave any marks
sorry but this last stretch will not be
pleasant
the constant laughter you've had for 15
hours
could lead you to pass out
fainting is caused by a temporary drop
in blood pressure
your brain doesn't get the blood flow it
needs and you lose consciousness
it could cause you both mental and
physical harm so please
don't try this at home with yourself or
your
friends okay by the time you reach the
end of this challenge you'd have lost
control of your body
you wouldn't be able to regulate your
breathing and
you would be very stressed
you could have asphyxia a brain aneurysm
or a heart attack
yeah so to answer your question
yes you can be tickled to death get me
out of this now
if tickling isn't your thing well how
about dancing think you could twist and
shake for 24 hours
all right then let's party
we'll see what that challenge brings on
another episode of your body on